president biden's big promise to
nominate a black woman to the supreme
court not polling well with the majority
of the american people 76 percent want
the president to consider all possible
nominees for the position rather than
laser focusing on a black woman but the
white house says americans are just
overreacting
the president's is going to select
a a woman a black woman who is qualified
who is prepared who has impeccable
experience to serve on the court what we
can assure the american public of
whether wherever they fell on that poll
is that
he will choose
and nominate
someone who has impeccable credentials
and is eminently qualified
and despite that poll we showed you
earlier the media thinks any criticism
of biden's supreme court plan is just
for ratings
but let's be honest
fox wants a fight
right-wing radio and tv wants a fight
they need a fight over the supreme court
they are already starting a fight
that's rooted in white identity politics
all the fox's primetime shows are
outraged that biden has committed
denominating a justice who is black and
female
so i have absolutely no problem with him
nominating a justice who's black and
female reagan uh said he was going to do
the first female guide sandra day
o'connor greg uh trump uh wanted to
replace rbg with the female he got amy
comey bryant what's the big barrett
what's up i don't even care it's a break
even for dems right they're gonna
replace a lefty with a lefty so keep
your powder dry it doesn't make a big
dim that's funny listen to pillsbury
doughboy talk about ratings
they are in the gutter i mean they're
literally dead i mean
they double their ratings when they
watch their own shows that's how bad is
it so we don't we don't have to slump
for ratings we don't have to divide a
country to slum for ratings the way cnn
does but the dems and the media will
make this about equality equity history
bigotry misogyny all the e's but it's
not about that it's about politics you
the design here is to serve up a
non-white non-male selection to buffer
against any or all criticism right they
want the theaters designed so that
the critic let's say i'm the critic or
jesse or dana's the critic thinks twice
about engaging any kind of negativity
because you know you will be called
misogynistic or you will be called
racist so that is it's all a force field
this has always been a force field do
not be fooled that they're playing
tolerance because they don't care about
any non-white person if they don't kneel
before their ideology they will destroy
you they will destroy you so do not
believe this is about tolerance or race
this is about creating a buffer zone but
it is dana about politics i mean reagan
was about politics with senator day
o'connor he wanted to get to the female
vote in 1980. uh trump was about
politics with amy coney barrett he
wanted to get the pro-life people really
energized about his it's always about
politics but also like for like look at
amy coney barrett remember during the
hearing they asked her what notes she
had taken and she held up a blank page
because she didn't need to take any
there's there's a lot of brilliant
people out there that could be
considered and one of the things that's
really interesting is um the diversity
angle i like this idea the diversity of
thought
so michelle childs who is one of the
possibilities who apparently um
congressman clyburn likes and senator
graham said very positive things about
this weekend she went to public school
she didn't go to the ivy leagues and
that's the kind of diversity that i
could really get behind i would also
just like to take a quick trip down
memory lane if democrats really wanted
to see a black woman elevated to the
supreme court why did they block janice
rogers brown back during the bush
administration and i will never forget
it because anonymously they sold the
papers the newspaper the papers that's
what we used to call the media
that it was because they didn't want the
republicans to have a shot at nominating
the first woman
black woman to the supreme court and
janice rogers brown would have been an
incredible circuit court judge and and a
supreme court justice she didn't get the
chance that's gross that's gross yeah
they did to uh
remember
they were
janice rogers brown and estrada were
around about the same time and i
remember it because i was um
i was responsible for the judicial
nominees at the time oh it's quite a
responsibility and competent very
competent very well but there have been
only two black men only uh you know uh
there's only one
uh hispanic woman one woman of color now
nine come on little affirmative action
goes a long way i don't care about any
of that geraldo i care about the
suspense
you don't just say who you're gonna
nominate before you do it you build
suspense you build drama you say it's
all out in the table i'm in my who knows
who i might nominate could be anybody
and then when you do nominate a black
woman say you want a denominator the
whole time then you throw it down and
everyone goes whoa black woman supreme
court this is huge and then the media
goes crazy because of the glass ceiling
and they love it and everyone's like wow
and it's but then now it looks like he
got cornered by clyburn to get the
primary vote i mean whoever gets
nominated is going to be it's the result
of a backroom racial deal that was cut
so a white democrat could win the
nomination that's the truth i mean and
you're and you're over seasoning the
identity politics of this right
shouldn't be what it's about i mean the
meat of this is her jurisprudence is is
her intellect is her judicial philosophy
and all the focus now because the press
is so into the identity politics it's
just on her skin color and i think that
takes away from her whoever that person
may be one thing about stelter we don't
need a fight
we're crushing it he's lost half of his
audience biden needs to fight cnn needs
a fight that's who needs the fight
shouldn't they have just aimed for a
black woman without telling anyone just
stay we're like everybody we're like
this one right
and told him to say it he promised it
during the debate when clyburn went up
in the middle of the debate and said hey
you better answer that you know promise
and get on stage and he did on the stage
he said i'm going to nominate the first
african-american woman to the united
states supreme court so it was already
out i mean you know it could have been
differently it could have been different
but you know what i found interesting
that there was a poll that said 28
of non-whites
uh uh only one in four 21 of non-whites
want a black female so it's very
interesting that this identity politics
i mean who is it for when there's only
like a quarter of of of people of color
who want a black female and i also think
that tulsi gabbard said it best when she
said the last time he said he was going
to pick someone based on the color and
sex i.e vice president he picked uh
kamala harris and that was a disaster so
i don't think he's too good at picking
people for a position based on identity
politics america's sick of it especially
on a court that will be deciding the
issue of affirmative action i mean it's
contraindicated
kelsey gabbert my favorite politician
and i want a black woman on the supreme
court hey sean hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to fox news youtube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else